Boston Dynamics new robots will make
soldiers obsolete here's why military
robotics technology is not far behind as
our world becomes more advanced if you
have seen Corridor digital's parody
video
[Applause]
oh you may know what the future will
look like don't worry the realism of
that video is a testament to the
advancements in visual effects at the
Los Angeles Production Studio and not
necessarily robotics but to be honest we
are not far behind and in this video we
will explore a company and its line of
robots that are leading the charge to
make soldiers obsolete Boston Dynamics
if you haven't heard the name before you
may be surprised to know that a company
is leading the charge in this area they
are called Boston Dynamics
Atlas is the culmination of over a
decade of hydraulic humanoid robotics
work at Boston Dynamics a leading
robotics research and development
company in America they have been
exploring how the military can benefit
from Robotics and all the ancillary
technological innovation related to that
for a long time a leading robotics
research and development company in
America they have been exploring how the
military can benefit from Robotics and
all the ancillary technological
Innovation related to that for a long
time so today let's take a closer look
at this company and its line of robots
that will eventually make soldiers
obsolete Boston Dynamics has over the
years gained popularity by sharing
amazing demonstrations of their robots
on social media even if you're not
familiar with the company per se you'd
have definitely seen the video of a
dog-like robot being kicked around and
carrying heavy loads the company located
in Waltham Massachusetts was initially
founded as an offshoot of a research lab
that developed robots at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology or
MIT in 1992. in 2013 the company was
sold to Google X and alphabet
Incorporated subsidiary four years later
in 2017 the SoftBank group based in
Japan bought it when Boston Dynamics
first came into existence the goal was
to improve movement and rough terrain
capabilities and robots 30 years on
their goal now is to imagine and create
exceptional robots that can be used for
various military and civilian
applications regarded as leaders and
Pioneer is in robotics with their robots
already capable of Performing
unimaginable Feats Boston Dynamics is
surely coming close to achieving its
goal so with the introduction of this
mind-blowing company out of the way
let's look at the amazing line of their
robots and why we think they will
someday make soldiers obsolete Boston
Dynamics robots over the years Boston
Dynamics have created and tested many
bipedal and quadrupedal robots some of
their most iconic robots are the legged
Squad support system or LS3 a
militarized version of big dog their
first successful quadrupedal robot this
ruggedized robot is designed to operate
in hot cold wet and dirty environments
it can maintain its balance with heavy
loads on its back under extreme battle
conditions allowing it to be actively
tested by the US Army as a squad support
element
foreign
the next on the list of iconic robots is
the spot mini a compact and agile
four-legged robot that can Scurry around
your office home or Outdoors the spot
Mini Takes the experiences learned by
Boston Dynamics while developing big dog
and LS3 and incorporates them into a
quiet all-electric four-legged robotic
dog with astonishing rough terrain
mobility and Superdog strength this has
already allowed it to be used as a
sensing and exploration robot for
various civilian and Industrial purposes
[Music]
thank you
then there is Handel a robot concept
that was designed for Material Handling
and efficient warehousing the research
led to the creation of stretch a fully
automated industrial robot that is
currently used for efficient Warehouse
operations
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
there is atlas a six-foot bipedal
humanoid robot designed for a variety of
applications and tasks I'll talk about
Atlas in Greater detail later in this
video as this robot is more likely to be
the test bed for a future robot Soldier
foreign
[Music]
odd years Boston Dynamics has added many
other robots to its illustrious lineup
however it's impossible to go through
them all as this video will become too
long although all these robots have one
thing in common they all act as a force
multiplier allowing humans to step back
and allow the robot to do its thing and
as Boston Dynamics produce more and more
such robots that slowly get integrated
into the civilian and Military world the
company has also diverted its attention
to ethical programming in the world of
Robotics programming Boston Dynamics is
the champion of this type of programming
and has heavily invested its resources
into its research if you just learned
about ethical programming don't worry
you're not alone ethical programming is
a set of principles that encourage
programmers to be honest and aware of
their responsibility to protect human
rights when writing computer programs
when it comes to military robots ethical
programming is what will influence robot
decision making making it especially
important because these machines will
eventually be making life or death
decisions now that we've discussed all
the various robotics research championed
by Boston Dynamics let's turn our
attention to the robots that will most
likely make soldiers obsolete Atlas
robot remember when I said I'd tell you
more about the atlas robot well here
goes the atlas robot is Boston Dynamics
best product to date it's also the most
complex and technologically advanced
robot in its lineup when talking about
military robots that can do some actual
soldiering Atlas is perhaps the only
candidate in the world suited for it
first unveiled in 2013 when it was
starting to learn how to walk the atlas
robot team has since made great strides
the robot learned to walk just like we
all did by Falling a few times before it
got it right and the team has shared
their achievements and Milestones with
us on their social media throughout now
the atlas can walk run at a speed of 2.5
meters per second jump do a backflip
balance on one leg and even shake its
tail feathers I think that the last bit
is the only thing a human can beat it at
right now but Atlas already has the
upper hand because it will keep
developing and maybe one day it will be
the best dancer in the whole world
before that happens the Boston Dynamics
Team planned to have the atlas robot
Drive climb ladders put out fires shut
off valves open doors and operate
powered equipment in environments where
humans cannot survive because the atlas
was developed to Aid emergency services
in search and rescue operations it has
the greatest potential for soldiering in
the future which is probably one reason
why U.S government research agencies
like DARPA are also said to be heavily
invested in this project along with its
impressive motor movements the
scientists behind the project have also
been working on developing a paradigm
shifting neural net AI that powers Atlas
required for a control perception and
estimation happens on board with three
computers this AI has allowed Atlas to
become a self-learning robot as
mentioned earlier with the example of
walking just like a human baby atlas's
AI trained itself to walk run jump avoid
obstacles and even help to make
decisions based on its environment with
every failure and use case presented to
it the the AI learns and tries to
extract the most out of its mechanical
body so this robot represents a true
Synergy between mechanical parts and an
ai-powered programmed brain that's why
Atlas can potentially make soldiers
totally obsolete in the future currently
Boston Dynamics have military contracts
under an early adopter package for a few
robots in their lineup of robots more
excitingly some of their robots have
already been field tested with
satisfying results looks like robots may
just join the military sooner than we
expected so let's take a look at the
type of robots that are used and can be
used by the militaries around the world
type of robots for military there are
three types of robots that militaries
can choose from these are automatic
robots automated robots and autonomous
robots the first type automatic robots
are robots that respond to external
inputs in a mechanical way these robots
have no ability to discriminate the
inputs so they will carry out a command
as it was given indiscriminately they
also have no ability to function without
those inputs usually a human being is
operating it the this means that these
robots need human controllers they may
go out on the battlefield and reduce
human soldiers there but they will need
a human being's input in the control
room to function automatic robots are
already highly used by armies around the
world think of mine clearing robots or
EOD robots that neutralize IEDs and bomb
threats moving right along we go to the
second type the automated robots these
are robots that carry out commands in a
chronological and pre-programmed manner
most automated robots are predictable
because they are limited by algorithms
determining how they operate and behave
this means that automated robots can be
programmed to identify enemy forces in a
specific manner or even have their path
to the enemy camps programmed into their
navigation systems automatic robots
exist in today's armies as well such as
pre-programmed reconnaissance drones
that fly without human input or fire
control robots that are programmed to
spot enemy vehicles and call in the
artillery automatically the final type
of robot the autonomous robot is the
cause of much debate these are robots
that can be programmed to be able to
make choices between different options
even though they are still constrained
by their programming they can exercise
independent judgment using high-level
artificial intelligence this is the type
of robot that will eventually make
soldiers obsolete depending on the
battlefield scenario and mission
objectives an autonomous robot can
decide who may appear as a threat and
respond accordingly they may lead a
group of other autonomous or automated
robots and accomplish complex
Battlefield objectives that now require
human Soldiers the ultimate form of
Boston Dynamics Atlas will fall into
this category of robots despite its
challenges you can see why the
militaries would be interested in such a
system the idea that you don't have to
suffer human casualties to achieve some
military objective is too alluring for
any army command to pass on that's why
we see huge amounts of Investments being
poured into autonomous drone research as
well various Air Forces have already
started work in this field with the
ultimate goal of creating fully
autonomous drones that can fly detect
threats make decisions and kill without
any human interference although there
are huge challenges to overcome before
any of these systems come online not
just technical but also moral and legal
but it's quite a future we're heading
towards so let's end this video by
quickly taking stock of the advantages
and disadvantages of autonomous robots
fighting Wars instead of humans
advantages every technological Paradigm
has advantages and disadvantages the
most obvious Advantage here is that
robots fighting Wars can save countless
human lives they do not possess emotions
so they can't experience fear or trauma
they are tireless and can achieve
extraordinary Feats of Strength that no
human being can they can be sent into
terrains and temperatures that no human
being can survive such as nuclear waste
areas and extremely hot or cold
temperatures all this means that they
can participate in hugely dangerous
missions and Carry Out orders with the
same Precision every time autonomous
robots can be updated and upgraded
regularly these soldiers can be upgraded
in less time than it would take to train
human soldiers also since they are
manufactured products there is the
potential for mass production so
Replacements should be available at much
less cost but they do come with some
disadvantages disadvantages as great as
those advantages sound there are a few
disadvantages to having autonomous
robots in the military the first and
most obvious one is that autonomous
robots fully rely on their human
programming so they are vulnerable to
hacking imagine having your army of
robots hacked by the enemy and used
against you now that's a Terminator
style nightmare waiting to happen
besides hacking since they are
mechanical things they can malfunction
on the battlefield and fall into enemy
hands although there is much debate
around this there are potential risks
associated with artificial intelligence
especially armed AI that has been let
loose on other humans but even if we
assume that the future autonomous robots
don't take over Humanity there is still
the risk of having the few who control
the technology oppress the many who
don't have access to it now that's a
dystopian future that I certainly don't
want to see happen so you see there are
a lot of moral and ethical conundrums
not to mention legal maneuvering
required before humanity is allowed to
integrate fully autonomous robots as
soldiers in their regiments however we
as a collective are inexorably heading
towards that future let's hope that
companies such as Boston Dynamics and
governments worldwide consider all the
possible eventualities and consider all
challenges before developing these new
robots that will eventually make
soldiers obsolete they definitely have
their work cut out for them to ensure
that their robot soldiers will value
human life even as future Wars become
more dehumanized so what do you think
about the future of military robotics
when you imagine autonomous robots as
soldiers do you get excited by the
possibility or does it raise more
questions than answers let me know in
the comment section below and if you
enjoyed this video hit the Subscribe
button and continue watching the next by
clicking on one of the cards on your
screen see you in the next one